people really only buy one thing they
buy into stories some people are gonna
like you thinking about look at that
person you know they care about status
everything you hear you hear quotes all
the time do not you know we shouldn't
doesn't matter who you are and not a lot
yeah a lot of those quotes aren't very
accurate being stupid lowers you on the
totem pole you don't have to be Albert
Einstein but you can't be dumb lead
motivation what a top ten with believe
nation
what's that belief nation is Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from being a college
dropout being broke and having a sleep
on his mom's couch to being involved in
over 20 multi-million dollar businesses
and starting one of the largest book
clubs in the world with over 1.5 million
subscribers he's Tai Lopez and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
volume for joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one stand out with your story
people really only buy one thing they
buy into stories that's why Steve Jobs
and Apple did well people buy this story
of Apple it's like this hipster company
that it's not even what the company is
its the largest corporation in the world
that's what it really is but they
position their story is like you know
hipster and artsy and all that and so
grit capital you got to ask yourself I
call it the brand story what's the brand
story here what's you in the brand story
has to stand out that's what I mean
about who what where when why who are we
what are we doing who what where where
can you find us when in the why the last
one is important because why is like why
you should do business with us versus
all the other sources of capital and
that's your the why is the most
important part in they're all important
but it's the most forgotten part you go
to people's websites there is no why
we're different and people just think of
this tinder dating when you're flipping
all you're doing is looking for
differences if imagine if every tinder
profile was a blank no picture and just
said I'm a male I am you know six foot
tall I'm this age I live in this city
that's raw data you would never go on a
date with that person because why are
you different from the person they're so
good tinder profiles differentiate so
that most of your website should be why
you're different people get it you're a
capital so you're a fund or your or your
investing people with capital they get
that and they've heard of it but it's
like what can you do for me lately
that's what people care about what can
you do so like if people ask like ty
what's you know what's different about
you I can sit there's different things I
can say but one of them is I'm a call I
didn't go to college
I grew up in a mobile home I was born
dissent raised by single mom I lived in
a you know didn't inherit a business I
went out and found five mentors these
are all unique stories that people don't
hear every day they assume if you're
doing well in business that you went to
Harvard Business School or your parent
you and your dad had a business and then
you took it over that's not my story
I'll close by telling you this this is
how you figure that out it's very simple
I call it the waiter/waitress test every
restaurant you go to every Starbucks
barista every person sitting next to you
on the subway just start talking and
then you got to look at their pupils
body language tells you a lot when
people aren't interested they'll kind of
like okay and they'll like look at their
phone or like but if they like turn and
are like huh and if they ask you
questions that's how you really know
smart if they're like well what do you
mean by that like and so tell different
versions of the great capital story or
whoever's listening your company tell
different versions be like so I could
for example the reason I have this story
that I'm telling you now because I've
tested different parts of my life member
your life has different stories you can
tell you can tell the story when you're
eight nine ten eleven twelve all the way
up to your current age so we all have 50
different stories about ourselves
you start talking every waiter or
waitress you meet which of and then you
pay attention if they always when you
tell the story number 17 if they always
go wait what then use that as your main
story that's called pulling your
audience
you have to pull the audience those
entrepreneurs are doing it in the 1980s
business style where they just tell
people this is what you better like
about me you know the world's too
competitive now you'll fail quickly that
way so let that's where what that's
where Sam Walton was right the
customer's always right as a group not
as an individual so if you talk to your
customers and 90% of them like story B
don't tell story a
so you got to get out there and talk to
strangers every business website is like
what's the least human version of me
like how can I just make it so you don't
have identify with me that's my goal how
can you not identify with me that's what
I'm gonna put on my homepage then
they'll put on a little sub page about
us and then you can scroll down there's
a little picture then if you click on
that 18 clicks later you find this
awesome story forget that good story
right on the front right here
rule number two find your fuel
motivation is different than purpose
I'll give you an example so if I say my
purpose is to get a million kids in the
ghetto reading books I do a lot of stuff
with a reading that's kind of one of my
things
that's a purpose so that's I like to
think of purpose as vision but vision is
relatively pointless because I've never
met a person successful or very or
unsuccessful who doesn't have a vision
take your friend who never does anything
the laziest friend you have if you sit
down with them and you go what would you
like to accomplish in life they'll tell
you they'll talk for it just ask people
what they'll do if they win the lottery
the one point what's it at now only two
billion dollars I read that if you
bought eighteen hundred tickets a week
since the time of Christ you still today
would not have good odds that you'd win
so two thousand you that wasn't some
professor at USC put that out so
everybody has a vision for what they
would do if they won the lottery but not
everybody is the motivation to get there
so I think of a GPS in my car I think of
your purpose as the end goal that you
put in map quite your Maps so you say
I'm going to the Grove in LA so you
punch in a grove that's great
but it's pointless when there's no fuel
in the car then it's just a dream so the
question becomes what is the fuel that
motivates and drives you so let's say
your thing is
status you see other people with status
and you're like oh that would be cool to
walk in the room and everybody
recognizes me and stuff like that well
didn't allow yourself to go there when
you wake up in the morning you're like
I'm gonna do XYZ because one day people
gonna know my name
and I don't know if my primary driver is
status but as I looked through my life
there's been times when there's absolute
signs that it was for example when I was
left when I was came back from the farm
back to the modern world from the Amish
I went to a night club in Raleigh North
Carolina I wish I had footage of this it
would be very funny because I went to a
night club it was the top night somebody
told me the best night club and was this
place called the office so I knew
nothing about night clubs I'd been with
the Amish okay no night clubs there and
I wall I just went alone a dude just
rollin up to a nightclub alone if you
don't have our night clubs the
prestigious one they're not gonna let
you in so I go there and I'm kind of
like okay there's ropes you know they're
letting all these other people in and
I'm like okay can I go in and the dude
just like he just laughs he didn't say
anything it was like right just and I
remember thinking oh one day I'm gonna
own all these clubs and I ended up
basically running that city's nightlife
at one level so that's what I'm saying
that was status I wasn't like ooh I
wonder how much money they're making at
this place mine was like I didn't like
to be disrespected and I've seen that
over and over in my life so now I just
came to grips with it some people are
gonna like you thinking back look at
that person you know they care about
status everything you hear you hear
quotes all the time do not you know we
shouldn't doesn't matter who you are and
not a lot yeah a lot of those quotes
aren't very accurate the status is
status is important you know and in
status is very very powerful and if you
use it for good
it's kind of like Bill Gates he's
clearly driven by money you do not
become the 17-time richest man in the
world without being hyper competitive
Paul Allen his business partner so the
two most competitive people I've met in
my life
or Michael Jordan
and Bill Gates and Bill Gates you better
believe he cares about money but yet
he's turned and harnessed that into the
charity that's in some ways maybe done
more good than all governmental
organizations for the last hundred years
so that's why I say he's been able to
pull it off and if each of you could
find your version of that for some of
you it's like you pulled up in a car and
everybody laughed at you and you know
and you're like one day I'm gonna pull
up on a nice car when I get out this car
people gonna look at me and be like
Bob's here Susie's here and in a suit
you don't have to feel guilty for it
that's my main thing as long and I think
I won't have time to go through this but
as long as you start filling so this is
the selfish side we started talking
about as on you start filling up the
unselfish side it will offset the
negative connotations that society has
okay
with whatever drives you rule number
three turn negatives into positives I
was in a crib and two adults were
yelling but my mom came in the crib and
was like it's okay and my mom I could
remember my mom crying so my very
earliest memory as a human is
instability my dad was like a big he was
a pro bodybuilder it's a big strong guy
and I would tell people about my dad
like he was still in my life I never
told them because they'd be like well
where's your dad and I'd be like oh he's
busy he can't come but the truth was he
was getting cared that much my mom says
hi
when I was pregnant with you FBI kicked
down the door with guns put guns in my
face took your dad away and brought him
across the country to Terminal Island
off Long Beach I remember was my
birthday my dad when he got out of
prison he he just stayed in Long Beach
but for that birthday my dad's like I
will drive down and take you out to
dinner and he said he'd be there at like
5:00 p.m. and she had to go to work
she had a night shift job and she's like
okay your dad will be here soon so I'm
gonna leave you out the house alone so I
sat there I was kind of on the couch and
I remember waiting for my dad
and it was like 5:30 came nothing
6-nothing
we had a home landline like waiting for
the phone to ring seven eight I remember
being like super sad going but you're a
little kid so you're like I'll have
hopefully he's still gonna come in just
late he's just late you just late I
don't remember how long it was but my
mom said she came home at midnight I was
just asleep like literally like on the
couch just like looking out the window
and he never came and so I remember that
being like super painful and being just
like my dad doesn't care about me life
will throw tremendous blows at you
you'll have the betrayal of a close
friend or family member you'll have you
know sickness death life is painful if I
perceive it as what it was supposed to
be but the second I switch it and go
wait no life's like a puzzle that I was
handed here's your puzzle light of life
tie we took a piece out the dad was gone
and when I look at life like that my
life's like an adventure and I'm
thankful for even the stuff that sucked
in the most painful day and sometimes in
the moment I couldn't see it there but
in hindsight I'm like but I wouldn't
have found that puzzle piece rule number
four leave your comfort zone what a
Drake say if you don't have haters
you're not popping if you just start
doing stuff you start posting that
person you thought the friend you're
like oh why you got to show off what you
got to show off that's the person that
you kick out of the circle people should
either be giving you constructive
criticism they don't always have to
approve everything either constructive
or they should be nice you don't need
anything else in that circle you will
make the average of the five closest
people to you that's an old saying guess
your five closest friends income is the
average friend make it 30 to 40 and
you're making 50 so you're the best one
in the group you don't want to be the
best one in the bubble you want this
bubble to be full of people that
intimidate you all growth comes from
being intimidated if you're always
feeling comfortable comfort comes from
being from status right you feel good
around your friends you know your status
with them you're comfortable when you go
under group
you know if right now Elon Musk
Mark Zuckerberg all these people walked
into this room and said come to dinner
with us we're all gonna chat about
business gonna share you you might be
like oh oh I don't know what I'm gonna
do I don't have anything to contribute
good that's the room you want to be in
rule number five think big think big my
mind still running through all the
conversations I had with Arnold
Schwarzenegger last night in his kitchen
talked to him for about an hour's one of
the greatest conversations I've ever had
and that's one of the takeaways think
big you know he told me he said he
always thought big he said don't worry
about failure so much died how far can
you really fall we're all only a few
feet from the ground and I was thinking
mentors you know he told me about his
mentor reg Park his first mentor and I
thought that's what's wrong in the world
that's why it's so easy to feel lost who
do we have guiding our way you know you
got to go out you have to find people
you have to find people who have done it
before who can shorten the path who can
keep you from failure he told me he said
don't fail too much one of the reasons
he doesn't procrastinate and can think
big he said is because he he at 20 years
old won mr. Olympia so he said he got
used to success and he tasted success
and so you know make sure you find some
little wins in life don't always lose
it's a myth that you only want to learn
from mistakes what do you learn from
mistakes they don't have to be yours
though people in the modern world with
all this convenience we have the next
thing you know all you're doing is just
sitting around not accomplishing
anything you know go out conquer the
world conquer your fears
think big that's all I could think you
know he's a big dude strong but his life
was big made some mistakes made a lot of
great
attempts and successes rule number six
recreate your life nobody in my family
had ever really made money and you know
they say poverty is systemic and it's
true like most people you can't rise out
of like your socio-economic class like
one of the biggest predictors of where
you'll be in life is where you're born
it sucks
breaking the cycle is something that has
to start happening in the world and what
broke the cycle for me was like
realizing that I was doing it wrong I
was in a mobile home in Clayton North
Carolina and I did not have a job I
didn't have a resume I didn't have
anything to put on a resume I didn't
have a college degree just laying there
on the couch and when I was laying there
the question that came in my head was is
this it all my friends went to college
they had parents that have more money
and they had this and like I missed this
I remember just going to sleep I was
just depressed and the next day my mom
was there and she said you should read
this book Tony Robbins and I remember
being like oh I don't want some
self-help book but she's like yeah you
should read this book so I read it and I
don't remember that much what I read but
I remember the one-page and it said all
greatness starts with failure because
when you succeed you party and when you
fail you ponder and all greatness comes
from pondering your situation I remember
thinking that's what I was doing last
night on the couch I was like pondering
like what did I do wrong and and I made
myself vulnerable to the fact that maybe
I did make mistakes maybe I had to
change my life maybe had to listen to
different people maybe I had to try a
new path you know Einstein said the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over but expecting
different results and I'm like ty you're
being stubborn
so after I read that book I was like I'm
gonna try something new so I went back
in that mobile home I found the yellow
pages and I remember flipping through it
going to the financial section and there
was this full-page ad by this guy Mike
Stainback it said Stainback financial
services and I kind of pretended I
didn't lie but I kind of pretended I was
coming there to be a
customer and I get to the place and I'm
like I'm Ty can I speak to your boss and
I'll never forget he was sitting like
this like gum big like lazy boy chair
and he had this big mustache he looked
like Tom Selleck I wanted to be super
honest with him I said listen Mike you
don't know who I am but I know you must
be successful because you've got a
full-page ad in the yellow pages that's
all I know about you but I know that
costs a lot of money if you teach me
what you know about making money I'll
work for you for free and he was sitting
like in this charity was I was talking
to him this way and he was Silas and he
just slowly pivoted his chair you know
I've been looking for someone like you
for 20 years you come back in the
morning and I'll set you up with your
own office and you can work for me and I
promise you if you listen to what I'm
gonna say one day you'll hug my neck and
he did have an office but what he had
done was he cleaned out a closet with no
windows and he had put a desk it's where
all the filing cabinets was i sat down
on the chair and he plopped down pieces
of paper and said Cole call these people
I'll give you a percentage of the money
you make from them no guarantees working
for me so I just started calling and I
sucked at it I would coffee bought six
you know and after six at night they
were like all of you they were hanging
up on me I remember being like oh no I
think I've gone from nightmare to
another nightmare but I started to get
curious and creative
and I wrote down a few little different
things I would say to the people and I
remember in that first month I started
opening up deals for this might stain
background I opened a deal that was one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
commissions if the deal went through and
I remember going Wow life can change
like fast it within nine months I went
from zero dollars to making a hundred
grand I remember being like this is the
pinnacle of my life and I went out from
then like a madman I became a CFP a
certified financial planner I got into
finance I learned I read every book you
can either be paralyzed by what life
gave you and let the pain because there
will be pain that will be drama you can
either let it build up and like build
scar tissue that that just paralyzes you
or at some point you go the cars didn't
weren't dealt for me like I wanted and
so I'm gonna go recreate those cards
rule number seven get knowledge so just
knowing stuff makes you go up and if you
study status and psychology being stupid
lowers you on the totem pole I once went
on a date with a girl one of the most
beautiful girls in Los Angeles I'll
never forget I was in Santa Monica I was
at a restaurant and I was like we were
just talking I was like yeah I got to go
to Miami next week and she goes Miami
where is that I've heard of it and I was
like oh my god this is American - she's
like Miami I've heard of that she's like
is that Northern California so would you
do that no matter how you look nobody
respects somebody that's stupid does
that make sense you don't have to be
Albert Einstein but you can't be dumb
and most people are dumb you read 52
books a year I promise you your status
in other people's eyes will go up
naturally without you trying it without
you forcing it rule number eight
deserves success to get what you want
you have to deserve what you want the
world's not yet a crazy enough place to
reward a whole bunch of undeserving
people and a lot of people think Oh
world's not fair and that's true a lot
of things in the world aren't fair but I
will tell you this in general if you're
good at something
you will rise at the top it might take a
little while for people to recognize
your talent but most people give up a
year too early so at the end of the day
my philosophy is you can be entitled you
can expect things you can just think you
deserve them you can be like hey you
know and a lot of people are like that
in the model world they're too entitled
or you can just go out and say I will
make it I will force the universe to
give me what I want you know and that
works with making money
that works about in every area of life
and every time my life doesn't go as
expected it's because I don't really
deserve what I'm wanting Rula benign use
the law of 33% I just spoke on this
subject that I think is like the
ultimate puzzle piece you get this down
most your problems go away I called the
law of 33% basically you should spend
33% of your day around people who have
not accomplished what you've
accomplished yet you can help them like
you mentor them and there's always those
people and you need to spend time around
people that you can help and then you
spend 33 percent of your time around
people who are on your level like you're
about at the same level of a cop of what
you're trying to do
those are your become your close friends
you know those are the people you hang
out with on the weekend but the last 33%
is the magical one that doesn't happen
in our school system and almost no one
even tries to find these people
unfortunately it's been 33 percent of
your time around people who are 5 10 20
30 years ahead where you want to be and
if you do the math
that's like a couple hours a day and now
you can do with YouTube video so you can
do it with a book you can do it with an
audiobook you can do a face book videos
if you can start absorbing from the
world's greatest line download their
advice into your brain there are 40
years of experience in pain and reward
in making mistakes in accomplishing
great things in you could you basically
get like a cheat sheet and if you can
absorb that and this is what I tell
myself every day I wake up it's like
Thai law 33% we spending time with and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is support
others
how long you been playing
there you go man there's a hundred bucks
no problem keep playing the world needs
more art always support street musicians
the world needs more art music beauty
you agree on the now
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Thai on how to reverse engineer
success that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions it's time
to move from just watching in the video
to actually taking some kind of action
in your life or in your business so
answer these three questions on your own
you notebook talk about them with a
friend or leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one how can you use your story to
stand out question number two what will
you do this week to leave your comfort
zone and question three what negative in
your life or in your business do you
need to turn into a positive thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
you have to go out and find people who
are successful financially and reverse
engineer what they did reverse engineer
re I keep that little acronym in my head
it's one of the most powerful acronyms
that you can remember re reverse
engineer so for example when I was
starting out I was like what would it
take to become a millionaire and I'll go
alright
win the lottery a lot of people play the
lottery and then some people one or two
become millionaires but if you reverse
engineer I asked myself this one day I
started study what makes the most
millionaires what's made the most
millionaires and the United States
self-made not people who inherited their
money and the answer is tada real estate
now you don't even have to be trying to
make a million dollars or reclaim a
millionaire but just think about that
reverse engineer that and put it into
your life it's not just about a career
but it's about also passive income
because your careers active income you
work on your career you go to your job
even if you're an entrepreneur right
but what about when you're asleep here's
a crazy statistic if you just listen to
this for a second if you make what's
minimum wage let's say let's just say
fifteen bucks an hour that's thirty
thousand dollars a year right
but what happens if you make fifteen
dollars an hour
24/7 okay now that's 90 thousand dollars
a year
triple it but you can't work 24 hours a
day so that means you have to have this
movie call a passive income and passive
income means a lot myself in my own
living room here
oh god this way I was filming over here
so what I started doing is going I gotta
have my active income job career
entrepreneurship but I want to reverse
engineer the passive income that the
most millionaires have ever the most
what has created the most millionaires
ever sorry and that's real estate
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm
I understand why I'm here I think
because I am so open I wanted to think
I'm saying it's a bloody brief life all
of you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what gary
vee DJ khalid oprah and others know
about empire building that most people
miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video